foreign
I've been binging Attack on Titan
recently fantastic show but there's one
question that is eating me alive and I'm
hungry for answers how many people
can a Titan eat oh my gosh I've always
been fascinated by competitive eaters
Joey Chestnut the number of hot dogs
that man can eat would kill a normal
person I think you'd die
I'm I have indigestion I'm just talking
about it did you hear that an attack on
Titan was very attractive to me because
I mean essentially it's a show built
around competitive eaters these Titans
they just eat and eat and eat and they
don't stop
gosh darn it man just talk about this
give me indigestion but a question no
one has asked is how many people can
they eat what's their capacity but in
order to get to the bottom of that I'm
gonna have to talk to somebody who loves
Attack on Titan as much as I love eating
all right well you came to the right
place I know a lot about Attack on Titan
we don't know the inside structure of a
Titan because they kind of just
evaporate into air anytime they die we
could assume that the stomach makes up
pretty much the entire like chest cavity
chest cavity too why not they don't have
a heart they don't breathe they are a
stomach here's the main thing about
Titans though yes they eat people but
they don't digest them hmm they actually
throw up the people they're all chewed
up and sped out in a big like mushy ball
which is very gross your throat dump
like a throat dump thanks for that
it sounds like the first thing I need to
do is measure that bioball I need to
recreate it in 3D we know that Sasha
browse is five foot six if I can
recreate that angle and project the
texture down onto geometry I can create
a tube that is the same size as her and
then scale a ball that is the same size
as the bile ball now drum roll please
this bile ball is
2.6 meters in diameter there it is is
that upside down you fix that thank you
the problem is I don't know which Titan
it came from I've seen Attack on Titan
the Titan Shifters they don't consume
human beings so by process of
elimination anything bigger than this
we're worried about these ones these are
the people eaters Let's test it ooh my
favorite one did this bioball come from
the gluttonous Titan nope oh that's
really banking on the gluttons I just
like them I like a silly little walk
yeah beard and Titan
oh that's really close close it just
barely fits inside the stomach but you
can see like the shoulder blades just
not really going to get out that leaves
The Smiling Titan oh that's beautiful
look at that it's in your blood it's in
your DNA if it doesn't fit in this one
I'm quitting fingers crossed
oh that's a fit that's perfect yeah it
would need a little bit of squishing the
elastic nature of the neck can maybe
compress this gelatinous ball and then
it unhinges its jaw and oh that's a
bingo that is a good accent yeah but you
did thank you if only they had buttholes
you know I know they just said oh that
would rip you a Sunder that would be
yeah that's way worse yeah oh birth yeah
human birth I forgot about birth yeah
women do this women actually go through
that that is not dissimilar from birth
it's not much different I'm glad you
brought that up and now that we know
that this came from a 15 meter Titan we
can use this to extrapolate the data for
every other size of Titan
so now that we know the volume of the
Titan stomachs I need to get bodies in
tummies ASAP bodies and tummies that's a
crucial and I'm going to use Houdini's
crowd simulation tools to do that I was
able to find a Levi Ackerman model on
sketchfab you bite your food right right
I go a lot of these Titans do the same
thing they Chomp and so what I've
prepared is half Levi's got the upper
half and of course just the Levi jeans
the Levi G yeah exactly so these are all
rigged separately as separate agents but
I'm going to feed them all into the same
system and what's beautiful is as many
agents as you have as long as they're
set up properly they'll all interact
correctly and it goes Lightning Fast
let's do some orders rapid fire how many
how many Levi's you want I like to place
an order for one agent I want to feed in
and where'd it go
let's double it two Bots baby two order
up dump it on me baby so like oh oh I'll
take getting eaten by a Titan day over
this just a straight up nut shot from a
big old Bowl can I get 55 55 let's see
if we can just short those out real
quick
here they come
in my tummy 55 is pretty good how about
how about a thousand that oh
that's a jump
oh look at this they're dripping out
we're gonna need a bigger hole I think
they're getting crushed it's almost like
a sausage grinder at this point but it's
so fun to watch I know there are some of
you that wish you were in that pile of
Levi's yeah
so now that we've got all these agents
there's one thing left to do
oh you think I know I was hoping I know
I don't actually know yeah I know I'm
not really on the same page I'm not sure
what's happening to be honest with you
okay
oh how many people can attack me
we are mere moments away from finding
our answer I know the volume of the
stomach thanks to the Bible and I know
the shape of the stomach thanks to that
scene where Aaron gets eaten there's
just one thing that's still bothering me
as I started building these stomachs in
3D I also started diving deeper into the
science of eating
oh it's so disco I hate this
69. this is 69 hot dogs first of all
nice second of all Joey Chestnut he's a
small dude how does he fit 69 hot dogs
in there well he trains his stomach to
stretch a common misconception is that
the bigger you are the more that you can
eat but the reality is it's a technique
thing size pales in comparison to skill
at the end of the day this is shocking
horrific and so impressive to me
competitive eaters have insanely strong
Jaws light force of 280 pounds stronger
than a German Shepherd's bite what the
body is probably throwing indicators
left right it's interesting stop and
Joey's Minds say no no I'm just getting
started I mean you guys are insane
they're using everything at their
disposal gravity to force the food down
faster air pressure to push the food
down faster it's human Ingenuity at its
finest and this is what the Titans don't
have they don't have that Spirit right
they're there to just do it they're
smiling they're having a good time
whatever no Joey's there to work he's
there to put down dogs he's there to
expand and contract and masticate what
are you saying masticate you chew you
know what I mean
you can just say just say chew
if you think proportional right the
Titans might be eating more but Joey's
the better eater I think that if Joey
Chestnut goes Toe to Toe with a Titan
all things being equal he wipes the
floor with him when I started this
experiment I set out to learn a number
but the people need more than just a
number right they need a hero I have an
idea and it's definitely going to be
more work it will definitely push me
probably into the weekend a little bit
but it's worth the extra work to me it's
worth pushing a little bit harder to get
an answer that will perhaps even Inspire
more than just a maze I'm going to
embrace my inner Chestnut and keep
moving forward
you like anime right I love anime and
you know what you caught me in the
middle of working on our most ambitious
anime video to date it's such a giant
leap beyond the first one in terms of
the technology in terms of the story
we've had so much fun working on it and
it's coming out in a week but only
recorded initial.com wow that's awesome
and it's a lot more information than I
wanted so I have an attack on Titan
thing to show you if you wanna come with
me
dang what's up Mane gentlemen oh my God
thank you for coming we ran some
simulations and our wonderful young
intern here Emmett helps me build some
assets very helpful child that boy now
continue to be helpful and roll that
clip how many people can a Titan eat
[Music]
tiny boy baby how many can fit
[Applause]
[Music]
one only one body in a glutton is tight
wow I could probably fit one guy in me I
think you could I believe in you man and
I think you also just realized what that
means
[Music]
all right
all right next up the nine meter Titan
oh is that red is this Ren oh I hate it
I hate it
oh it was even more that ain't bad
wow so I thought the progression would
be like linear but it seems like uh
exponential and it's actually amazing
how many more bodies you can pile into
just a little more area like that I was
surprised at the differential let's see
what a 15 meter Titan can do
[Applause]
[Music]
it that's loaded up so many how you like
that the sound effects here we go
all right
122 and a half bodies wow that's a lot
that is crazy that is exponential it is
it's exponential I used the right word
you did and now we know now we have
peace in our hearts cool yeah we do and
that's it right except we don't oh we
don't have peace in our hearts we have
one more competitor
one man has stood to say that he will
dictate what is and is not possible in
this world I speak
of this man
[Music]
he's so tired of normal size come on
Joey for he has broken reality and
all time Pours Down around us now at
once this is so hyped come on Joey and
they say he shall live forever for he
does not do it for money he does not do
it for Glory he does it for his people
he does it for his country he does it
for freedom
good
Ness
it's on baby
[Music]
what do we got who we got
I don't know you don't know I don't know
how many this is that number has been
tallied and will be revealed to all of
us right now now Joey brings some
techniques to the table here that the
Titans don't his drive to masticate
viciously in public
taking into account the mastication
everything was bit in half the
restrictions on the joints I've softened
them a lot two important changes that I
believe more accurately simulate what a
human with Joey's capabilities could eat
if he were the size of a Titan titans
are otherworldly they don't have
internal organs and I think that that
gives them the edge here who will win a
monster born and built to eat or Joey's
Titanic spirit
foreign
[Music]
that's our boy born to eat we love you
Joey Chestnut
[Music]
there you have it if you enjoy videos
about heroes who expand check out this
one we already made about the Hulk and
whether or not his pants would rip it's
a good watch
ready yeah go
it's disgusting my throat it was a bad
idea that's a bad idea